well brian sentencing for a hip-hop  producer has been pushed back  again and the i-team has learned a  little bit more about why there's been a  delay  jamal rasheed also known as molly mall  admitted  he was a pimp in las vegas he faced  federal charges and pled guilty to use  of an interstate facility in aid of  unlawful activity now according to court  documents obtained by the i-team  rasheed was hospitalized with cobit 19  in july  his lawyers say he doesn't want to risk  contracting the virus again  a doctor's note indicates he has  internal bleeding and he has a  diagnostic  diagnostic test that's coming up next  week so his sentencing has now been  rescheduled for january 27th  the sentence specified in the plea deal  is one to 33 months while the maximum  sentence could be  up to five years